there will definitely be more on that in
the coming days
well Bobby Fischer made a comeback to
become world champion and Mom dear oh he
will have to make a comeback
to tie this first match in the final in
the aim chess rapid your Crystal Duda is
in the lead and he will win this first
match with a win or a draw so what's
happening on the board well my major off
is in the mood to take risks Ivanka this
last Pawn push is only ever played by
top players when they really want to win
yes and I do believe that Duda should
say yes to the challenge and step
forward with the porn don't play
anything else yeah we want the fun yes
and he does it he takes on the challenge
and uh here we have what is this called
I can't remember I I've kind of written
the dubious opening for black yes I
called it something in my notes but I
don't know but this is one line that I
have played where the bishop comes out
puts pressure on the Knight and uh this
was not the best move I actually had a
nice system against this particular
variation is much more common actually
to develop the uh the queen to protect
the Knight and uh now I advocate just
capture the night yeah White's Bishop
can capture that black knight it can
ruin the pawn structure for black there
also the advances that Black's made on
the queen side right especially that
black B5 point it's undefended you gain
some time against that okay Duda has
gone for the most principled approach
with an exchange and this tends to be
regarded as very pleasant for white
because actually the structure in the
center as well White's Pawn on D5 Square
just clamps down on the black position
you have full control over the light
squares often and I play this position
with actually reverse colors when I have
a Tempo more
um with when I have white but basically
doing what black does and even then I
really don't like it so here we go white
light squared Bishop was pointing at a
pawn now white puts even more pressure
and that pawn has had to move before it
was too late
um and now White's Knight can come out
from the queen side which Bishop can
move why it's the first to Castle I sent
for Duda but Mama jar has imbalanced it
that's what he needs to do if he wants
to win this game and he develops his
Knight so this Knight is on a great
Square because it's gonna jump onto the
dream Square which is the it on C4 and
what mama jarov he has to take risks so
he pushes forward with his doubled F
Pawn and I love this move from Duda just
clamping down on the left side of the
board knights in his dream Square Pawn
is in his dream Square the only thing
that white has to worry about is the
power of this dark squared Bishop yeah
it is very powerful though
um you mentioned that phrase how are we
ever going to contain this dark Squad
Bishop this piece is unrivaled White's
traded off his dark Square bishop and it
cuts across the board the main tension
will be later on this Pawn right this is
the big weakness it's defended by
White's Knight first of all
okay it's defended again for a second
time by White's rook and Duda has to
hurry and get his King to safety before
things open up
beating White's Bishop to just kind of
step one square
you mentioned this Outpost your anchor
it's really nice but uh where does it go
next this night does it just stay there
it stays there forever and ever and ever
just a thorn in the black side because
um if the Black Knight if it wants to
develop I mean it can't really develop
to the D7 Square because some pawns are
loose the D6 pawn and I do like duda's
last move even though it looks a bit
strange
um developing the bishop to Long
diagonal yeah but uh I also I like what
dude is doing I also like what mama
jarro's doing moving his rook and the
computer really likes black I've got to
say computers often like the bishop pair
so this is why but in the current
position look at Black's pieces they are
coming to life this Rook is on a nice
file now some point later maybe not
right now but later you can come attack
this night I'm expecting the black queen
at some point to move just to defend
this pawn and then like you said the
Black Knight can develop uh maybe the
black Bishop can kind of come to this
square and attack this white knight it's
a very imbalanced position
the one thing I will say from White's
point of view is it looks really nice
and pretty but there's no plan and I
found that when I've studied these types
of positions before so I like what dude
has done in general but I think there
were maybe slightly better ways of doing
it
um usually in these positions when I was
studying white should have wanted to
push his Pawn forward earlier just while
it was possible because now it's too
late black clamps down on the Square if
you can't push pause this white you lack
a plan yeah so yeah it's still still
very tense both sides have pluses
minuses in their position black also
can't push any pawns so a bit
frustrating that but can Duda
yeah can he just hold the foot or will
Mama Jara find that activity that he's
craving you've been studying the old
classics hauska against Ramon Edward and
the house cat against LaRue his two
grandmas I was actually winning both
games but I drew
is this a French specialty to French
Grandmasters playing this opening
against you yeah and it was actually
within the same month as well so it must
have been something that they kind of
cooked up or was going around
just around the uh the world at the
chessboard at that time that this
perhaps was a good way for black to
unbalance things but I was like no no no
not against me
and and there we see a Duda maneuver his
night and I agree with you David I think
it's very difficult actually for Duda to
come up with an active plan and Mama
jaro well he doesn't need to be asked
twice he pushes Harry and his idea is to
push Harry one square more and
destabilize the white king and that's
why Duda reacts immediately by copying
yeah but uh pieces are gravitating
towards the king side now Black's night
for example is coming over towards that
white king
still very tense Duda not fast at all it
looks so calm I would not be as calm
with white I've got to save just because
firstly the match situation uh you kind
of you have the lead you want to be 100
sure you don't blow it away with whites
you don't kind of make any rash
decisions but he's blitzing uh navajara
has gained a minute since the game
started uh both of them it feels like
they're impatient to get to the action
point of the game and wow the evaluation
part of reacting oh it came suddenly
from nowhere so much I mean there's no
tactic there's no checks in this
position there's no good captures
maybe there's a threat that you can
create why is the bar so far and White's
favor I guess it's maybe just the fact
that the black light squared Bishop is
now misplaced and now you open up one
line finally we talk about Pawn breaks
white should be playing on the queen
side that's where he has most of his
pieces his pawns are very Advanced for
white on this left side so he's opening
up lines Maybe mamajarov
not quite ready to meet this and uh okay
just as I was praising what he was doing
evaluation Bar says okay slightly
careless and the problem is you can't
keep everything blocked now you have to
trade off a set of Pawns before white
took you and Plex Rooks look good but
they are staring against concrete there
they are staring against the wall of
white Pawns
so I'm expecting white now to use the
only fully open file that's the B file
and at some point shift his Rooks over
there yeah I agree with you that and I'm
just looking at the bar and I'm seeing
it slide even more in White's Direction
there's no tactical shot I think it's
just simply that White's position is
just very overwhelming because of this
open line
and black has just no targets whatsoever
yeah but then again for a human it feels
like black is relatively active yeah so
it's Duda is not going to know that he's
got this massive advantage
I don't know if you saw this position in
Ivanka if without the evaluation bar if
you were playing for example from the
white side which you have in the past
this opening
you would think oh maybe slightly better
but I don't know what would you be
thinking here I was thinking when I was
playing against these two players I was
thinking I'm Caney I'm winning it yeah
and crushing
um but if I were facing mama jarov I
would be again very aware of him making
active moves and I do like his night
jump with the idea of relocating to the
Santa just asking questions to the queen
but the problem though I mean if I go
deeper
there's no there's no point actually
but there's a threat on the board I
think for black maybe to sacrifice this
night and to blow open the position for
example if white wastes a move uh I'm
not sure how it just moves The Rook for
example uh then Knight takes Pawn could
be maybe an issue just to make sense of
these black Rooks and after the
recapture Sunny Blacksburg Sprint to
life the White Queen has to move
somewhere and another Pawn might drop
you get three pawns for the piece this
bishop might suddenly come to life uh
maybe on this diagonal that's why okay
he stops this idea Duda he Retreats his
Knight I like this one just keeping the
square over protected even if that line
I showed wasn't good for black you don't
want to risk it right you don't want to
allow things to change
especially against someone like Mama jar
of don't let him attack so you defend
White's Rook is coming in as well it's a
really nice Square Outpost for The Rook
to enter the black Camp the night wasn't
doing anything there
uh The Rook from that square would
attack this Pawn in conjunction with the
White Knight
yeah maybe
time for Mama jarov to give up material
and try to initiate the random chaos
button but it's difficult to find I was
thinking maybe step back with the bishop
okay step back with the bishop yeah I
mean I really can't see any no no the
the light squared Bishops with this
bishop yeah and if White's Rook comes in
I was kind of hoping to
you really don't want to go passive in
this type of position okay he steps back
with the queen oh maybe his idea is to
get the queen active somehow but
to me it looks like uh Mama Jarvis about
to be seriously on the back foot after
this Rook idea
coming in dude it doesn't blink he plays
it instantly
how do you stop this I mean for example
if if you have to just go passive like
you said as black just defend maybe at
some point you can dream of pushing this
Pawn forward getting the black queen out
he does play this but you're just so
slow and uh White Rooks can come out
team up against this black Bishop kick
it away
would be the first move I think about
Force the bishop to a passive square and
then again
you still look at the position you know
black has only one Pawn break and if you
control it
what what next yeah black wants to push
this Pawn so that his Queen can jump out
towards the white king but like you say
you can just bring your knight over and
just cover the square if you need to you
can also for example start creating
threats the root can move across you can
bring your other rook in try to pin and
win but wow he finds a tactic young
Kristoff Duda has he just won a pawn if
we go back to the game situation he's
just taking this Pawn with his Knight
maybe that's uh just a really strong
move uh the black Rook has to take this
Knight it was too strong and now the
Black Brook can no longer defend its
Bishop so white is one upon
looks like a very good idea unless black
has something now the valuation bar does
judge that white is winning
yeah very important Point blacks Rook is
a bad blockade as well it's going to get
hit by the White Knight
yeah and uh the white Pawn on D5
comfortably defended I
I must admit I criticized young
Christoph duda's opening like I couldn't
quite see a clear plan but he's shown us
exactly how white should play this
position and against this variation and
it's been model play so far and this was
a move that I had on my radar many moons
ago but it just looks like it doesn't
quite work
he's gambling totally I mean he's kind
of hoping for Duda to capture that pawn
with the wrong Pawn
so would be the G Pawn but of course
that's fine to be honest I think you can
take this Pawn both ways and um yeah I
agree I don't really want the black
queen to swoop out
but are you surprised he won't go look
at the clock types my major are still at
nearly 15 minutes and it's moved 26 and
he's had to make some critical decisions
some crucial moments just bypassed in
this game almost yeah it feels like
they're playing Blitz it feels like
they're both just itching to get to day
two of the final
well that's a problem for Mama jarov
though because you do not want to be
starting day two in a must-win situation
and the way it's looking now I mean he
will be definitely losing this much and
tomorrow will be a big ask
yeah
it feels like with black he's trying to
whip up too much he's trying to create
too much and dude is just not uh kind of
backing down dude is calling him out on
his mistakes and
um you've mentioned this move uh Ivanka
with Duda thinking now for over a minute
you mentioned there's one way you would
take back you would take back this way
most likely or most likely with the
e-pawn just to preserve the Integrity of
the pawns there on the right they will
defend each other that's nice uh if you
took with the other if if you take the
other way sorry uh then the black queen
at least gets active and although you
can defend by bringing the White Knight
over you control squares you defend this
Pawn with the white Rook although you
can get away with this still looks good
though it does look very good to me
um okay he goes the other way I think
the other way is the more natural one at
least and uh yes black gets one check
black can throw his rook in with a check
but this is easily blocked right the
White Knight steps back
yeah this is the problem with opposite
color Bishops as well unless you can
break through completely your opponent's
Bishop will be able to control one color
complex and we do see this position on
the board The Black Queen shifts over
where's she coming where's she going I
don't see it I don't see it I think she
just did it just simply to prevent the
white Rook swinging over and offering a
trade yeah wides for it can't do that
but Waits For It steps across and
White's Rook is coming up too try and
pin the black queen okay The Black Keys
had to move but white is two pawns up
surely there's a way I mean even if you
take the slow approach and just kind of
try and kick away this black Rook
looks good feels like black has no
threats it looks very convincing David I
think as long as you keep one Rook
around the second row just to defend
keep everything protected you can't go
wrong yeah this is the only weak spot
for white this is the only Square black
can ever break through on so just keep
your Rook defending it and
should be winning Alpha Duda plus five
the computer says just with a bit of
care he's got plenty of time as well he
should be wrapping up today's match went
all wrong for mommy are not only this
game but today or has it gone all wrong
for him or or Duda just really good
strategy today not giving Mom Gerald any
chances yeah go to praise Duda just in
general every facet of his game the
openings when dudas had Black Rock Solid
the last game he could have been the
more ambitious maybe but when the
critical moments came he made safe
decisions got a present for that with
white Duda two games ago very impressive
this game
very impressive again I'm struggling to
uh find
you know superlatives for him because
he's just been so impressive yeah a very
composed calm it's nice when a player
keeps control especially with white you
don't want to let it get too crazy here
larger was throwing everything at him
but he's saying okay I'll take your
pawns I'm still defending and I think
that's the strategy against these great
attackers you just have to say super
super calm
um sometimes they attack you it's
inevitable you just gotta be able to
control things when that happens and
there we go
um trying to trade off pieces two pawns
up
getting rid of Black's defensive Rook
makes a lot of sense it definitely does
and of course my majara cannot make that
trade so he steps back but uh you step
back I go forward is it now time to stop
pushing the d-pawn yeah white has a very
strong past D Pawn you can maybe be
greedy and grab Black's a porn I was
just thinking that as well I think I
probably would capture that pawn because
after all two better than one yeah
actually it's three uh White's already
two pawns off oh okay yes yeah three
points I don't know if you need to be
that greedy yeah we do yeah stunting I
don't see any reason not to be
essentially
there we go three pawns up now for Duda
wow approval and uh still I mean take a
look at the white uh King side I mean
the bishop and Knight they're Sterling
Defenders they hold everything together
and uh Duda gives a shake of his head
takes a sip of water and uh just gets
ready for what Shaq is going to generate
yeah he's trying his best Jack The Black
Queen is now in the white half
again no threats everything is protected
everything's covered the only loose
piece for white is white Rook on the
second rank that's the only piece that
might get tactically
um it's a tactile weaknesses you call it
your Banker just because there'll be
some double attacks where it's loose
undefended but
shouldn't be enough and look at Muhammad
yarov
looks like he is uh already giving up
and this game is
has lasted for 31 moves and he still has
14 minutes and 47 seconds left on this
clock that is only 13 seconds less than
what he started with
horribly wrong this must have gone yeah
I think it was a bad opening Choice
somewhat you know because Duda just
played it very confidently he knew all
the plans that needed to be done and it
was very very effective somehow
mamajarov never got going and yeah he
leaned back just there and he said to
himself okay you need to go into hustle
mode uh Coffee House chess is in order
you need to just push your pieces
forward put them in random positions
hope for the best because ultimately
Duda is winning and if he navigates this
with Precision he will walk away with
match victory yeah some players against
certain opponents Shaq might still be
feeling confident in hustling and
swindling but dude is so good when he
you know needs to defend or needs to
find a narrow path and he's yeah he
calls his opponents out on the Bluffs so
um okay he's going for the seventh rank
now the black king is just as weak as
the white king to be honest so why not
three pawns up and on the attack Duda
yeah it feels like my major have just
lost his composure he forgot that
you can just play on your opponent's
nerves he tried so hard to avoid a force
draw in the opening but he ended up with
a losing position by move 20. so um yeah
there's different strategies you go all
out but then you can risk burning your
Bridges and being
you know losing a one-sided game or you
just keep the tension but you risk maybe
walking into a draw so it's
swings of roundabouts but it hasn't gone
well for Shaq in this one and I have
noticed actually the older players when
when it gets really tense really nervous
like aronian they play Super quickly
there's a case in England as well uh
Jonathan Spillman very strong
Grandmaster
great guy former world number three
three I think yeah one of the best plays
in the world the older he gets the
quicker he plays just because I think he
doesn't want the tension and he just
wants to kind of rush through things and
nobody enjoys sitting there and
calculating it's not that much fun so
for Shaq chess is fun but it's also his
job so
I don't know I think he wants the fun
part but without the stress without the
calculation without the boring side oh
that's sensible and also with experience
maybe you can trust your gut feeling
more your intuition more exactly yeah
and less to lose once you've once kind
of further in your career you're like oh
I've achieved a lot already I can play
with freedom when you're young it's like
I need to win this I need to actually I
need to prove to people
um so that's why I think Iranian as well
he's become so much quicker in Rapid
dress
especially on the tour that's very
interesting I hadn't really noticed that
I always had gone by the assumption that
the older you are yeah the slower you
are you know you sit down you need your
cup of tea
you need to get yourself in the right
frame of mind you need to take that
pause and go but uh I agree but uh but
David is right it's the more nervous you
get it's it's like you know when you're
a child you're free you're a band you
know you can just jump off all those
things and you don't care when you're
you're an adult you kind of know what's
in store and you know what's ahead and
uh tension it's stressful I heard that
comes at the age of 27. the last thing
in the brain to be developed is the
consequence Center and that develops at
around 27. wow that's interesting
actually yeah it was around that age
where I started yeah being a bit afraid
I know against the younger players I was
like oh I don't really want to take this
risk just what if they beat me yeah but
until that I was like yeah I'll Attack
I'll sacrifice a rook running man I
don't care but uh okay interesting 27.
so okay so every uh everyone watching
out there you know it's never too late
but uh if you're younger than 27
. take those risks yeah be aware of it
right it's that's uh very important and
uh I do like duda's move he just uh
moved his book to B7 Square
works the Rooks are now defending each
other
beautiful defensive and uh also he's
threatening to drop down with the B2
work and offer a trade and of course
because he is material up peace trades
will help him yeah for example if uh
black defends this Pawn that's a bit
loose The Rook is kind of attacking it
it's tied down at the moment but for
example let's say black steps back
sensible move and juvanka's idea just
retreating getting rid of this the most
active black piece trading it off and uh
okay black and win one Pawn back but
that's not going to be enough you're
still two pawns up with white and long
term this Pawn is just going to win the
game so um yeah that's in his pocket
Shack anytime he wants it most likely
and the reason uh in this position sorry
that the black queen doesn't really want
to go and take this Pawn is that
suddenly there's no more tension no more
attack on this Rook freeing up the other
Rook Rook takes Pawn now and white is
going to break through against the black
king so yeah full control how can black
even improve his pieces it's not clear
this piece can't be improved it's gonna
uh guard the advance of this Pawn the
black Bishop can't be improved but that
Knight can't really be improved
just no way to increase the momentum and
it's only Duda who can improve his
position this Pawn is marching and this
Pawn is under Fire from White's Rook
okay well you know he was all these
pawns down why not be one more and there
you go he offers another porn well I
mean white can simply capture that I
mean is there anything four pawns are
better than three four pawns up for Duda
now yeah
and uh I mean also there's a big threat
of white simply pushing the a pawn
forward as well
it's just devastating he's such a great
position for Duda yeah this one has been
complete dominance it's been very
one-sided and uh as well another really
instructive example of using your time
uh yeah you shouldn't play this quickly
no matter what it's move 33 Shaq still
has nearly 11 minutes left but you don't
take that game you don't take that time
with you to tomorrow you don't take it
to the next game
what's the point having 10 11 minutes if
you're completely lost yep four pawns
down like one one Pawn back but now
white wins a different one and the Rooks
are both coming to the seventh rank we
call them the blind pigs they'll just
devour anything in their path and one is
going to come right now yeah there's
gonna be two Rooks along the seventh row
do you think we're gonna see a
resignation
soon Shaq looks in pain there we go
the problem is the black Bishop can't
move if it does the white Rook will
slide behind the black king checkmate
yep the computer says Plus 13. this one
is not going to last too much longer I
think we'll see Shaq resign and uh yeah
we have it we have it we have the result
oh it's over a loss in game four and
also a loss in the match for Muhammad
Yara of oh he doesn't look happy and so
doesn't young Christoph do that but he
must be happy inside because a match win
in the first match here in the final is
very good news for young Christoph Duda
if he is able to just tie the match
tomorrow or win it he will be the winner
of the aim chess